Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus
Vorletzter Tag des Jahres es ist fast
vorbei und ich frag Dich nicht wo du
morgen sein wirst ob du Silvester feiern
wirst du wirst einfach sein ja ich werde
einfach sein sein so sein und da sein
genau wunderbar Richard ich freue mich
auf diese letzte Ausgabe also einen
kleinen Jahresrückblick wollten wir mal
wagen und zwar habe ich mir überlegt es
wäre doch mal schön über die Dinge zu
sprechen über die bisher noch nicht
gesprochen wurde es wird ja alles zu
Tode gelabert und wir sind daran auch
durchaus beteiligt dass eine oder andere
Mal aber es gibt Dinge die wurden nach
unserer Auffassung nicht so richtig
gewürdig die sind so ein bisschen
untergegangen weil es ein paar große
Themen gab
auf die sich alles gestürzt hatte die
rechte Mittelpunkt standen
deswegen lasst uns heute mal über ein
paar Dinge sprechen die vielleicht
abseits davon passiert sind und jetzt
sind das finde ich ist eine gute Idee
aus dem darf man ja nicht vergessen ne
also Aldi fürchterlichen Dinge die da
passiert sind und so weiter ist ja immer
der eine Film genau und der andere Film
sind ja auch die Dinge die mit einem
selbst passiert sind und die ja manchmal
gar nichts damit zu tun haben was auch
schön ist ne also es gibt so diese
berühmte tagebucheintragung von Franz
Kafka ja da hat er irgendwie notiert
vormittags im Freibad nachmittags erster
Weltkrieg wow wow
also völlig völligatorisch ja auf einer
Ebene und ich glaube der der der
Schwimmunterricht in der glaube ich
hatte der war in dem Moment glaube ich
weniger als der Ausbruch ist erst weg
Krieges und wenn ich so an an das Jahr
zurückdenke dann dann bleibt
wahrscheinlich am relativsten in
Erinnerung die Reise nach Uganda und
woanders ich hatte das ja erzählt von
den
plötzlich nur noch nass und Regen und
grün ja und eben nicht die das Grau und
und und und und die Kälte von dann jetzt
und so weiter vor Augen ne sondern dann
gibt es so so dieses innere Lagerfeuer
an dem man sich wärmt ja schön oder auch
in anderen Begriff zu nehmen ich habe ja
als Kind eigentlich alles Erdenkliche
gesammelt ich habe da ja nichts
ausgelassen und was ich auch gelassen
habe war jetzt nicht so ein bisschen
Jungs artig sondern ich bin ja unter
ziemlich viel Mädchen groß geworden
waren Glanzbilder hast du Glanzbilder
gehabt als Kind Glanzbilder Glanzbilder
sagt dir das was nee
bei uns in der Familie gab es nur
landsbilder
Entschuldigung Entschuldigung er musste
sein
ich weiß nicht
eigentlich schon wie gesagt Menschen
gedenken also weiß ich spätestens hat
ein Kaiserreich da sind dann irgendwie
so Engel und dann ist da so ein bisschen
so Glitzer dran okay
genau das gab's noch in meiner Kindheit
ich bin ja deutlich älter als du und
damals gab es das noch ich habe
sozusagen die letzten Jahre der
Glanzbilder noch mitgemacht ist schön so
und dann sammelte man die und dann
tauscht man die und so weiter an
irgendwann hatte man einen Stapel mit
vertauschbaren glanzbildern und mit
unvertauschbaren glanzbildern also die
schon so ultimativ schön waren dass man
die nicht mehr rausrücken wollte okay
und irgendwann endete dieses Glanzbilder
tauschen damit dass alle nur noch
unvertauschbare Glanzbilder hat und
seitdem ist das für mich so ein
wichtiger Begriff in meinem Leben
unvertauschbare ganz langsam
das war für mich so ein unvertauschbares
Glanzbild also in diesem Jahr hast du
auch unvertauschbare Glanzbilder von
2022 aus diesem Jahr meinst du ja also
es gibt ich habe ich habe immer so so
Bilder im Kopf die ich ich war
irgendwann in diesem Jahr in Lappland
unterwegs in Nordschweden
das ist zum Beispiel so etwas was ich da
bei mir eingeprägt hat und das ist
beides weil es war ein gewisser Weise
auch ein bisschen traurig war der
wärmste April der dort jemals gemessen
wurde war damit Hundeschlitten unterwegs
und war aber gleichzeitig halt auch
dieser Zauber der Arktis nicht ich
könnte jetzt einmal tief Luft holen ja
eine Stunde wieder ausatmen wenn man den
Zauber der der Arktis so beschreiben
will ja dieses er liebt dich selten so
glücklich als wenn du über Kälte und
Schnee redest wirklich ich meine ich
erinnere mich daran wie du wie du über
Südtirol sprichst ja ja und das gleiche
auch wenn du wenn du von der Arktis oder
sprich ja Polarregion oder so du hast
irgend so ein Inuits oder ja weiß ich
gar nicht aber mich hat das wirklich
immer fasziniert das Interessante ist ja
dass dieser Zauber der der holt mich
dann immer wieder ein ich hatte
irgendwann im Herbst ein ziemlich
schönen Auftritt in der Eishalle in der
großen Eishalle hier in Hamburg da habe
ich Bilder aus der Arktis gezeigt und
wir haben jetzt glaube ich irgendwann im
Februar noch mal einen Termin in Lübeck
oder so und ich habe mich damals gefragt
wieso mache ich das eigentlich nicht
öfter weil das mich auch selber immer
verzaubert ja du stehst dann da und dann
geht das Licht aus und dann hörst du so
den ersten Hund heulen und dann kommt
der Wind und es ist egal wie wie ich das
schon gesagt ja egal wie hässlich die
Halle ist jetzt die Eishalle über
wunderschön aber es gibt manchmal so
mehrzweckhalden kennst du auch und nach
30 Sekunden bist du weg und tauchst
wirklich einen in diese Welt und das ist
das so der Zauber und da ist in mir der
Gedanke entstanden dass ich definitiv
das ist der eine gute Vorsatz für 2023
ich werde wenn es irgendwie geht in
diesem Jahr immer nach Grönland Reisen
definitiv okay und wie wenn du wenn du
noch mehr Dinge machen willst als im
letzten Jahr wovon möchtest du im
nächsten Jahr weniger machen
du bist eine total gute Frage ich
würde jetzt spontan sagen es ist alles
gut wie es ist das ist auch ein großes
Glück das empfinde ich als als Privileg
ich
arbeite
durchaus
so ein bisschen vor mich hin ja aber ich
habe das nie als große Belastungen
empfunden aber ich habe in diesem Jahr
angestoßen von Genre me von Matt kennst
du denen das ist genau Bewerber Legende
wenn du so willst
generemy hat irgendwann Kontakt zu mir
aufgenommen hat der hat so eine Kunst
Installation gemacht und ich kenne ihn
eigentlich gar nicht aber er schrieb
mich irgendwann an damals noch ganz
förmlich Persie und so das ist jetzt ein
paar Monate her und schickte mir so ein
kleines Auge Fall zu und in diesem Audio
falsch sprechen zwei Menschen die man
kennt nämlich Anna los
und ihr Göttergatte Jan Josef Liefers
und in diesem Audiofile das war eine
kunstinstallationenken wie es wäre wenn
alles erzählt wäre auf der Welt einfach
alles zu Ende erzählt und sie sagt dann
und dann was und er dann ja und dann
Stille
und niemand sagt mir was nein niemand
sagt mal was auch nicht Markus Lanz nein
auch nicht macht
die Geschichte und es war so es ging es
um die Frage was ist wenn irgendwann mal
alles erzählt ist ja und das schickte er
mir zu und ich war total begeistert
davon ich fand das ganz großartig und es
geht auch durchaus auf meine Kosten aber
ich fand es trotzdem richtig gut und
dann kam mir ins Gespräch und er hat mir
dann berichtet von einem Projekt dass er
schon lange verfolgt nämlich ein
lebenszeituhr kennst du das Projekt
also Genre me von Matt macht dir wenn du
das möchtest eine Uhr lässt der
Hersteller ja also irgendwie haben
Schweizer immer was mit Uhren zu tun und
er baut lebenszeituhren das heißt der
gibt in der Uhr und auf der ist
dargestellt deine Restlaufzeit
und schon mal richtig schlecht an
irgendwas nicht wissen willst
er sagt aber ich habe mir überlegt weißt
du es ist wie bei einer Tüte Milch ja
wir wollen ja nicht wissen wann diese
Milch in diese Tüte eingefüllt worden
ist Zeit ist immer so sagen wir gucken
immer nach hinten sondern wir wollen
doch nach vorne schauen ich will
eigentlich nur wissen wie lange ist
diese Milch noch haltbar
ist das mit uns auch wir wollen doch
eigentlich nicht wissen wann wir genau
geboren worden sind und was da alles war
sondern eigentlich wollen wir wissen wie
lange die Nummer noch geht
und das ist die Idee dieser Uhr und es
ist total interessant erzählt dort Genre
Mees mittlerweile 70 und erzählt dort
nicht in Minuten rückwärts sondern in
Sekunden weil er sagt es ist ganz ganz
wichtig dass ich auf dieser Uhr was tut
dass ich da was bewegt weil erst wenn du
wirklich siehst wie da die Zahlen so
runterputzen kriegst du ein Gefühl für
die eigene Vergänglichkeit ja gefällt
mir alles überhaupt nicht wenn ich vom
Ansatz her verfehlt also
Wertschätzung den wir nicht bekannten
haben aber nein einer meiner lieblings
Philosophen ist
ein heftiger Kritiker des Zeitmessen
auch nicht dass er das grundsätzlich für
sozusagen unsinnig hält oder so aber er
sagt wenn wir mit unseren
verstandeskategorien Versuchen die Zeit
zu begreifen und in einen rasterpressen
Minuten Sekunden Stunden und so weiter
dann hat das mit dem wirklichen Erleben
von Zeit nichts zu tun er sagt das
Vergehen von Zeit erlebt man nicht wenn
man auf den Sekundenzeiger guckt und
auch nicht wenn man seine Tage misst
sondern das Verstehen von Zeit merkt man
wenn man mit geschlossenen Augen
entspannt in der Sonne liegt
und dann ist das Vergehen der Zeit und
das in der Zeit sei nicht mehr
voneinander getrennt man ist dann quasi
Teil der Natur richtig also Bergson war
der Überzeugung dass alles was der
Mensch sich vorstellt sozusagen
abgeleitet ist auch Raum und so ja von
Größe und Dimension und das einzige was
wirklich wirklich ist ist die Zeit aber
nicht die gemessene Zeit das ist ja
schon wieder mit dem menschlichen
Verstand zu versuchen etwas zu begreifen
was wenn ich begreifen kann sondern die
intuitiv erlebte Zeit und das ist ja
eine Erfahrung die auch jeder kennt ja
manche haben das wenn sie am Strand
liegen na das wäre übrigens meine
Erklärung wo ich mich immer sag was
machen die Leute immer wenn ja
eins sein mit der Zeit ja das wäre
sozusagen die positivste Erklärung die
man dazu einfällt ja trotzdem lehnst du
es kategorisch abricher das wäre dein
Vorsatz für nächstes Jahr ja
komm jetzt ja das wäre das wäre so eine
so eine spezielle
von von von Serien dass man also
Menschen die sehr zappelig sind ja sei
es im Kopf und sei es auch sonst mehr
zwingt nichts zu tun ja um dann zu
gucken was für ein Quatsch dabei
rauskommt ja das wäre doch sozusagen für
RTL viel schöner als das Dschungelcamp
das ist ja auserzählt zu dem Thema Dinge
über die man nicht mehr reden müsste
wohl nicht mehr geredet werden soll ja
Ja Ja zum Liefers Thema quasi das wäre
Schweigen das beste ja es ist wirklich
wahr aber zu nichts tun ich glaube das
ist als Serie noch nicht entdeckt oder
als als Doku Fiction wir beide machen
das einfach mal wir legen uns einfach
irgendwo weil sie nicht an der Ostsee am
Strand
eine Woche ja und gehen einfach nicht
mehr weg und wir dürfen nichts tun und
wir dürfen nichts also dürfen uns
ernähren und so was
vorbei und bringen
weder unserer Kreativität noch unsere
Destruktivität völlig frei laufen lassen
weil wir uns nicht da weg bewegen dürfen
beide sehr schnell irre werden glaube
ich es würde passieren die Befürchtung
habe ich also wenn wir es bislang nicht
insgeheim längst sind werden wir es
spätestens
dann offiziell er wollte noch mal eine
Sache sagen zu der Zeit zu der Uhr ne
das ist genau die der Ansatz letzten
Endes auch von John Jeremy Format also
die diese Uhr ist nicht etwas
physikalisches sondern geht's eigentlich
um was philosophisches es geht also und
und die also was er auch sagt wenn ich
total irre da ist das mir ein bisschen
anders geworden er sagte eigentlich
leben wir alle so mehr oder weniger
schätze mal wie viele Wochen haben wir
auf diesem Planeten
ihr könnt das natürlich jetzt in Ruhe
versuchen halbwegs nachzurechnen
ungefähr 4000 Wochen also klingt nicht
so viel
ich auch sag mal kurz zusammen
am Ende des Jahres zu machen und am
besten jetzt noch ausrechnen wie viel
mutmaßlich von diesen 4000 Wochen ist
schon aufgebraucht habe ich habe ich
habe jetzt noch eine noch eine gute News
für dich deine deine deine Frau hat 200
Wochen mehr
das soll mich insofern beruhigen als das
in meinen Grabpflege zum Beispiel
ich finde das auch deprimieren ich will
nicht schlechte Laune machen aber ich
finde du bist auf dem besten Weg dahin
so zum Ende des Jahres nach einem
wunderbaren Jahren
voller Freude ja Ereignisse wirklich so
ein bisschen meine Stimmung wieder
drüben und die ganz ehrlich dieses Jahr
wenn man mal ganz ehrlich sind ein
weiteres Jahr zum Abhaken oder irgendwie
was
angeht ziemlich genau
da habe ich von grauen Jahr gesprochen
so Corona ja und so weiter also auch
ziemlich deprimierend das können wir
jetzt nicht ewig die nächsten Jahre
wiederholen also ich finde wir sollten
mal auf die Dinge gucken die so ein
bisschen abseits des Weges sagen und
dann können die auch alles schwarz waren
oder ob da nicht auch ein bisschen paar
unvertauschbare Glanzbilder dabei waren
ja pass auf apropos landesbild fällt mir
direkt eins ein lass uns doch mal ganz
kurz hinten anfangen Richard wir gehen
einmal da so schnell durch ja aber ganz
hinten angefangen das war für mich das
Highlight also oder der Tiefpunkt je
nachdem
zum Jahresende diese griechische
EU-Parlament Vizepräsidentin ja und ich
habe in dem Zusammenhang gelernt es gibt
nicht eine richtige Präsident es gibt 14
ja super super Hölle wer braucht diese
Leute alle 14 Präsident wahrscheinlich
alle Dienstwagen und Chauffeure und
sonderbezahlungen und Prämien und so
weiter
so und diese Frau kommt der EU-Parlament
und zwar deswegen weil sie sagt wir
brauchen eine neue Art von Politik so
geht das nicht weiter und dass die Leute
alle so müde sind von dieser Politik hat
damit zu tun dass da lauter korrupte
Typen sitzt richtig ja und dann finden
Sie bei ihr zu Hause
Plastiktüten voller Kohle und ich dachte
wie retro ist das denn ja wer lagert
Geld und Plastik oder ist ihr das im
Plastiktüten übergeben worden was sind
das für Leute die Geld im Plastiktüten
statt im Koffern übergeben oder
überweisen
irgendwelche Panama ja also wenn man das
in dem Film darstellen würde ne ich bin
ja immer sehr skeptisch so was Realität
sind im Filmen anbelangt würde ich
natürlich sofort sagen so macht man das
nicht ja also wenn ein Wüstenstaat vor
hat Parlamentarier zu schmieren dann
wechseln da keine Plastiktüten mit Geld
hin und dachte ich auch ja verrückt oder
völlig verrückt würde ich mich nie
trauen sondern Drehbuch zu schreiben und
ich denke mir denken die Leute du hast
ja nicht die geringste Ahnung
Schwarzmarkt oder auf dem Basar ja
sondern du bist bei der europäischen
Zitron da macht man das anders es ist
wirklich krass und und es ist es
bestätigt wirklich die schlimmsten
Klischees und Vorurteile ich musste
denken an meinen Personen der mir vor
ungefähr einem halben Jahr auch das
sozusagen schon Jahresrückblick schickte
er mir an ein herrlichen Satz von George
Carlin kennst du denen
amerikanischer Comedian schwarzer
großartiger Typ der sagt immer wir
werden regiert von der faulsten und
gierigsten Generation die die Welt je
gesehen hat und es hat angefangen als
sie Sex Trucks und Rock n' Roll an
Marketingfirmen und verkauft haben um
sich noch mehr Einbauküchen leisten zu
können
ja schön gedacht wir sind da ein
bisschen weiter ich ich habe das nicht
für möglich gehalten dass sowas noch
geht ich auch nicht Richard pass auf
jetzt Sprung Jahresanfang am 9 märz in
der Tagesschau aber war nichts was mir
in Erinnerung geblieben ist die
Transplantation eines Schweine Herzens
eines genetisch veränderten Schweine
Herzens hat stattgefunden in Maryland
soweit ich das weiß
und diesen Patienten wurde als erste
Menschen weltweit ein Schweineherz als
ersatzorgan eingesetzt das fand ich
bahnbrechen und dachte wow was dann so
ein bisschen untergegangen ist nach zwei
Monaten ist dieser Mann verstorben David
Bennett heißt der
hat aber immerhin zwei Monate und das
ist das was als medizinische Sensation
und als Meilenstein gilt hat zwei Monate
überlebt diese Schweineherz ist vor der
Transplantation genetisch verändert
worden
vom Schwein und sowas
das ist genetisch verändert worden
sind zwei zwei gehen ja ausgeschaltet
worden sozusagen eins das an bestimmten
Zucker bildet weil das sonst eine zu
starke Immunreaktion ausgelöst hatte und
ein anderes gehen dass dafür sorgt dass
das Schweine Herz Gewebe übermäßig Weg
wächst das wurde sozusagen beides
eliminiert und das ist natürlich ein
wahnsinniger Fortschritt und und jetzt
etwas was nach zwei Monaten leider dann
böse ausging aber gleichzeitig natürlich
auch etwas was die Frage aufwirft was
bedeutet all das für uns und wie weit
dürfen wir gehen ist das ethisch
vertretbar naja Tiere als
Ersatzteillager und das machen wir ja
schon ein Buch darüber das machen wir
schon ganz ganz lange und ich denke das
hat jetzt keine keine schrecklichere
Dimension als die ganz normale
Tierhaltung zum Essen ja also das ist
hier von Nutzung von Tieren zum guten
Zweck für die Menschen so da kann man
grundsätzlich der Ansicht sein das ist
falsch ist dann geht aber ganz ganz viel
auf einmal nicht mehr das ist also jetzt
nicht ein besonders perverses Highlight
oder so dass man also ähm tierische
Organe benutzt oder dass man sie
manipuliert ich beschäftige mich ja mit
diesem bioethischen Themen schon sehr
lange leben und ich überlege sofort 20
Jahren war schon da gab es immer so
Prognosen ne was man alles mit Hilfe von
gentechnisch veränderten
Organen machen kann ganze Bereich der
Xero Transplantation wie der zukünftig
aussehen würde und was ich vor allen
Dingen daran feststellen
wie langsam wie langsam die Fortschritte
sind es ist kein rasanter Fortschritt
sondern es geht wahnsinnig langsam und
wir haben ganz ganz oft bei
gentechnischen Veränderungen dass die
die Immunabwehr sich da sich dagegen
mobilisiert
und das ist hoch interessant weil es
gibt ja andere Bereiche wo man mit
adulten Stammzellen zum Beispiel
arbeitet sowas also Stammzellen aus dem
halben Stunde Blut aus Milchzähnen und
so damit kann man unglaublich viel
machen und man hat selten diese diese
Gegenreaktionen des Immunsystems aber
hier in diesem Fall gehen technischen
Veränderungen haben wir ganz ganz ganz
häufig damit zu tun und ich denke immer
dass dieser dieser Weg der so als
zauberweg angepriesen wurde seit über 20
Jahren in den 90ern damit beschäftigt
wie dornig der ist wie steinig und wie
langwierig das fällt mir eigentlich auf
also man hatte sich eigentlich
versprochen das geht alles relativ
schnell und dann sind bestimmte
Techniken einmal da und dann wird das
Standard werden und dass das alles
erstmal so einfach eben nicht klappt
nicht in diesem Bereich in anderen
Bereichen nicht gerade sagte adulte
Stammzellen so da gibt es viele tolle
Sachen die gehen aber in dem Bereich
eher nicht so nächstes Thema nächste
Sauerei hätte ich schon fast gesagt
erinnerst du dich jetzt mal richtig
Gossip ja ich stelle mir jetzt vor du
bist Frauke Ludowig und frage Dich jetzt
wie du es findest das Will Smith Chris
rockt hat erinnerst Du nicht die
Oskar-Verleihung ja nicht mich daran
kannst du das sehr männlich in meiner
verteidigt
gut entschuldigung wenn ich dazu klar
sagen muss hätte ich auch gemacht was
wirklich ja also so also scheiß Witze
auf Kosten der eigenen Frau
jetzt mal im Ernstes falsch der Witz war
nicht gut wer der Witz war überhaupt
nicht lustig und er wird zwar nicht gute
und so weiter so und jetzt überlegen
jetzt nicht eine Vorlesung halten und
würde sagen ja die ethisch angemessenste
Reaktion in so einer Situation ist
jemand eine rein zu sammeln aber ich
meine man ist Mensch ja und man muss
auch Mensch bleiben dürfen und man muss
auch in der Öffentlichkeit sich ein
Stück intuitive Menschlichkeit großartig
und wenn meine intuitive Menschlichkeit
mir sagt der Arsch was macht er da und
die meine reinsemmel ist das für mich
ehrlich gesagt in Ordnung dass er dann
dafür nein eine Strafe zahlen muss und
so ist auch in Ordnung aber sowas kommt
doch vor unter Menschen ich meine was ja
was was was was was ist denn die
Vorstellung die dahinter steht natürlich
schon ja
[Gelächter]
mit fünf Jahren mit Judo angefangen und
da ist vielleicht rein Semmeln jetzt
sozusagen nicht die naheliegendste
Reaktion so und ich würde auch kein
plädo jeder für halten und sagen leute
ihr müsst euch mal zuschlagen soll ich
würde sagen wenn es denn mal passiert
ist das doch eine menschliche Reaktion
mehr will ich dazu ja gar nicht sagen
aber ich finde es ist ein Unterschied ob
du dich auf meine Schule ruft
verteidigst ja weil ich jemand
attackiert dass er was ganz anderes wenn
ich jemand attackiert finde ich habe mal
alles recht aber sich zu wehren aber
jetzt aktiv also der macht ja diesen
schlechten Witz und ehrlich gesagt könnt
ihr die Reaktion auch sein Alter ganz
ehrlich dieser Witz war so unterirdisch
dass das entlarvt sich alles selbst das
wenn man dann diesen Moment Ruhe und
gelassen ist so es gibt aber
Lebenssituationen wo man dann vielleicht
schon mal nicht cool und gelassen sind
und das gehört zum menschlichen Leben
dazu ja okay ja also ich bin auf Seite
von Will Smith so ehrlich ja ein Moment
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ne ich
tendenziell auch ich könnte also die die
die Idee dass da jemand sozusagen für
jemand anderen das ja der Punkt ne nicht
für sich selbst ich finde es wäre was
anderes wenn er den Witz auf seine
Kosten gemacht hätte also auf will
smithkost ja dann würde ich auch sagen
aber es gibt da nichts mehr als eine
Frau zu verteidigen das meine ich das
ist herrisch und wenn du dir jetzt
vorstellst der macht jetzt miese Witze
oder beleidigt deine Kinder dann würden
wir alle sagen hallo okay geht los jetzt
hier genau gar keine Frage mir geht's
eigentlich um was anderes Richard und
das ist der interessante Punkt mich
irritiert und eigentlich überrascht es
mich aber nicht wirklich diese diese
dieser moralische Furor der nach wie vor
über diesen armen will smita reinbricht
ekelhaft wirklich Ekel hat kein Thema ja
das ist natürlich mein Thema also ich
finde man sollte mal den Verbrauch an
Moralen normieren ja wie viel größer die
größte die größte von Nägel und
Schrauben also es gibt Leute die haben
in Deutschland Moral über der Schulter
jeder Gelegenheit komplett
genau ja und das ist natürlich in dieser
hysterischen hollywoodkultur ganz
besonders ausgeprägt wirklich ja mal
halblang ja dass man mehr Erdung ja das
tut auch eigentlich ein bisschen mehr
Toleranz ja du kannst sagen es ist
intolerant jemand eine reinzuhauen über
die Frau gemacht werden ja ich kann auch
sagen es ist intolerant sich darüber
monatelang aufzuregen das ist der Punkt
also was was mich was was und das ist
schon etwas was wo wir echt als
Gesellschaft irgendwie mal was zu
verhandeln haben finde ich also da geht
dieser Mensch hin entschuldigt sich
hinterher wortreichst unter Tränen und
so weiter so und nichts passiert und
Chris Rock lässt ihn abtropfen einfach
ein ums andere Mal sagt nur ich habe am
nächsten Tag irgendwie hatte ich einen
Auftritte bin ich hingegangen hat meine
Arbeit getan und bin wieder nach Hause
so was aber im Grunde ist es ein großer
Stinkefinger in der Zeit und das ist
auch legitim darf auch das hatte mir
Sicherheit auch verletzt und zwar nicht
nur in einem physischen sondern auch in
einem übertragenen Sinn
das ist nicht schön von den Augen der
Weltöffentlichkeit eine Geballer zu
kriegen vor allen Dingen wenn du dabei
auch schlecht aussiehst weil du weil du
den Kampf nicht gewinnst sozusagen
und weil doch nicht weißt wie du
reagieren sollst das überfordert ein ja
aber dann kommt jetzt noch mal Städte
noch mal so ein Video hoch wo dann sagt
du pass auf ich bin bereit lass uns
reden und wieder nichts das ist doch
eine ganz miese Nummer und abgesehen mal
davon
eingesammelt hätte ja der Typ häufigsten
Mann gewesen wäre hätte zurückgesetzt
ich meine die Option doch frei oder er
musste sich doch in dem Moment nicht als
jämmerliches Opfer darstellen ich komme
jetzt wohl du weißt wie groß ist
ja also wenn der das vor den Augen der
Weltoffenheit auf der Bühne auf der
oskar-bühne eine schöne gepflegte
Wirtshausschlägerei
spricht nichts gegen oder
okay ich sehe dich ab heute mit ganz
neuen Augen Richard ich will genau
dargestellt
dann ich mag das das ist irgendwie hat
dieser Besuch bei den Affen doch was mit
dir gemacht
und du meinst ich wäre dadurch noch
rustikaler geworden der Silberrücken der
sagt Freunde aber ich habe ein Problem
damit wenn wir den zivilisatorischen
Gürtel unserer Normen ja unserer Werte
und Gebräuche so dermaßen entziehen dass
man keine Luft mehr kriegt da drunter
und das tun wir genau an dieser Stelle
das heißt also der der Ausfall gegen die
kulturelle Norm ja weil der
Oscar-Verleihung jemand in eine
reinzusammen ja wird zum hyperskandal
so und wenn man jetzt noch sagen würde
okay da regt man sich einen Tag drüber
auf und dann ist das ist das Ganze
erledigt ja aber dieses
dieses ganz diese tiefe moralische
Grundierung die aus Will Smith jetzt auf
Ewigkeiten ein unpersonen macht dann das
ist ja das Problem womit der leben muss
ich glaube nicht dass er ehrlich gesagt
denkt der hätte sie nicht verdient
gehabt und hält den Fehler gemacht und
ich glaube einfach dass er sieht der ist
jetzt quasi gesellschaftlich zerstört
und geächte deswegen ist denn das für
eine Reaktion das meine ich ne ich finde
also ich zwei Sachen weil du mich eben
fragtest wie siehst Du das denn ich
finde ehrlich gesagt wenn du erwachsener
Mensch bist musst du dich eigentlich im
Griff haben kannst da nicht hochgehen
und Haus die man mal rein Betonung liegt
auf eigentlich ja okay eigentlich im
Griff haben
passiert und und so und ist so schlimm
ist passiert aber was ich dann so hart
finde ist dieses dieses Momentum des
Verzeihens das haben wir halt dieser
Gesellschaft irgendwie nicht mehr
sondern es geht bis zum bitteren Ende
bis der nicht mehr zurück bis der nicht
mehr kann und dann bettelt der und
bittet der und noch mal oder und es
passiert nichts und das finde ich so
hart und da fällt irgendwann auch was
auf uns zurück also der der moralische
Anspruch mit dem wir sozusagen das
verurteilen was da passiert ist der
fährt in dem Moment auf uns zurück weil
es ist mein Augen hoch unmoralisch nicht
immer mal zu sagen okay komm ist jetzt
gut du hast jetzt geleistet doch selber
zitieren der ja häufig den Verlust des
Katholizismus betrauert ja und wann
deren deren Stelle ist ein
unverzeihender Puritanismus getreten das
meine ich ja und dieses katholische man
macht eine Sünde und dann macht man es
wieder gut und dann weiß man genau ist
davon könnten wir durchaus mehr
vertragen ja
apropos unerbittlich ja erinnerst du
dich nur an die hubschrauberaffäre von
von Frau Lambrecht der
Verteidigungsministerin ich glaube die
habe ich nie so richtig wahrgenommen
also verteilungsministerin Christine
Lambrecht wurde im April bei einem Flug
in einem Bundeswehr Hubschrauber das ist
das kann doch London daran von ihrem
Sohn begleitet das war insofern okay das
war angemeldet die hat doch glaube ich
dafür bezahlt und so weiter
kein Kriegsgebiet mit dem Sohn nicht ins
Kriegsgebiet aber folgendes ist passiert
also die besucht einen truppenstützpunkt
in Schleswig-Holstein in Norddeutschland
um dann äh mit ihm Urlaub auf Süd zu
machen am nächsten Tag also fährt sie
mit dem Auto mit ihm rüber nach Sylt
natürlich der fatale Eindruck dass man
von Berlin nach Schleswig-Holstein mit
dem Hubschrauber in auf in diese Kaserne
genau deswegen fliegt weil Sylt halt
dann natürlich nicht mehr so weit ist ja
quasi an die Eltern weiß man was sie in
dieser Kaserne wichtiges gemacht hat
also sie hatte einen eine Abteilung der
der Bundeswehr sozusagen besucht von der
es heißt eigentlich kriegen die nicht
Besuch ja ja eigentlich nicht da kommt
natürlich der Gedanke macht ohne
Missbrauch verliert ihren Reiz so fragt
sich was geht im Kopf von jemandem vor
der Ding wenn man an die CO2 Bilanz und
all die Kosten eines hubschrauberfluge
auch das ja sich überlegt soll man diese
Strecke von Berlin nach Hamburg und dann
nach Sylt die kann man auch gut mit der
Bahn zurücklegen auch das ne dafür muss
man nicht mit dem Hubschrauber dahin
fliegen das klingt ja so als wäre das
sozusagen gegen die Rettung vieler
Menschen gegangen weswegen man den
Hubschrauber einsetzt genau hat mich
dann was geht in den Köpfen von Menschen
vor die ja wissen dass sie unter Dauer
Beobachtung stehen warum sie sowas
machen ja es ist Instinkt los und die
richtige instinclosigkeit entsteht dann
in dem Moment in dem sie das kam dann
jetzt zum Jahresende auch raus das wurde
immer bestritten aber sie hat ein Foto
von ihrem 21-Jährigen Sohn der da sehr
breitbeinig in diesem Hubschrauber sitzt
gemacht und da werden natürlich auch
Dinge klar ja du siehst die Umgebung
dieses Hubschraubers du siehst also ich
sag mal so da gibt es Leute die wissen
dann wie ein deutscher Bundeswehr
Hubschrauber aufgebaut ist und mir sagt
das alles nichts aber
militär-experten sag mal auch russische
z.B können daraus bestimmte Rückschlüsse
ableiten ja logischerweise okay darüber
hat in dem Moment keiner nachgehen keine
nachgedacht ich mein andererseits du
bist Verteidigungsministerin das müsste
die eigentlich klar sein und er lädt das
dann hoch ne so bei Instagram der
Klassiker und dann bricht die Welle der
Empörung über ihn herein aber ich finde
schon auf die Idee zu kommen und sagen
ich mache jetzt meinen Sohn Urlaub
nutzen wir noch mal Bundeswehr
Hubschrauber
was deinem Kopf vor sich geht würde ich
naja ich gerne mal Besuch Vorsicht
vorsicht ist
aber auch den Truppenbesuch hätte man
übrigens ohne Bundes
ist ja bestimmt ein Gefährt gegeben was
sie am Hamburger Hauptbahnhof abgeholt
hätte und zur Truppe gebracht hätte beim
Fahrrad
das wäre doch schade ist schade ja es
ist und unsere unnötig und irgendwie ja
ist das interessant ist immer das und
auch da wieder ne ähm die
dienstlosigkeit die die Leute dann
irgendwann mal so so heißt wenn sie sich
nicht klar als Politiker doch genau
diesen Instinkt ich meine wie gesagt man
steht unter Dauer Beobachtung genau
ja man weiß genau dass die geringste
Verfehlung vom politischen Gegner gegen
einfach verwendet wird man weiß das
Journalisten einem Auftritt und tritt
folgen und das ist einige Journalisten
gibt die einen überhaupt nicht leiden
können und die nach allem suchen warum
man sich dann ohne Tod einem solchen
ohne Risiko aussetzt das ist mir nicht
klar
ich habe sie seitdem nicht mehr gesehen
in der Sendung und wir haben sie
natürlich immer wieder eingeladen aber
sie hatte überraschenderweise keine Zeit
aber irgendwann wird sie kommen
weil du gerade Bahn sagtest wie fand es
eigentlich dieses neun Euro Ticket das
fand ich irgendwie eine gute Sache ja
also ich finde ich bin ja grundsätzlich
der Überzeugung dass der öffentliche
Nahverkehr zu teuer ist und der
Fernverkehr auch und dass man sich alles
Erdenkliche ausdenkt um den Menschen das
Reisen auf ökologisch saubere Art und
Weise günstiger zu machen finde ich ganz
großartig
ich meine der Nachteil an dem neuen
euro-ticket ich bin ja absolut
regelmäßiger Bahnfahrer
mein Leben in vollen Zügen den Scherz
hat Karl Theodor zu Gutenberg beim RTL
Jahresrückblick auch gemacht okay
ich kenne diese Pointe von Ulrich rosski
okay sagt die Ulrich noch was so ein
bachel der 70er okay okay ja und der
sprach von seinem Leben was ein vollen
Zügen genießt als er auf Tournee war da
habe ich das ja okay naja wie dem auch
geil also
waren darauf überhaupt nicht richtig
vorbereitet war ne und das war ein
einziges Chaos was dadurch angerichtet
wurde also eine gute Idee und eine etwas
ruckartige Umsetzung aber grundsätzlich
bin ich dafür dass der ganze öffentliche
Verkehr deutlich günstiger wird ja und
ich ich fand halt es war so ein Finger
zeigt in die Zukunft ne also sozusagen
entgegen der landläufigen Meinung dass
die Leute die eigentlich gar keinen Bock
haben öffentliche Verkehrsmittel zu
nutzen und so weiter stimmt nicht
und was ja auch passiert ist in der Zeit
die Bahn hat glaube ich unendlich viele
wertvolle Daten
generieren können darüber wo Leute
bevorzugt hinfahren wie sie dann fahren
ja wie sehr sie bereit sind umzusteigen
oder eben auch nicht welche Verbindungen
funktionieren welche nicht das ist
glaube ich ein ganz wertvoller
Datenschatz der da entstanden ist und
eigentlich ist das sozusagen so ein
Finger zeigt bei allen Holprigkeiten die
das hatte aber in die in die Zukunft des
Reisens so dann kommt Richard was auf am
29 juli total interessant für Dich eine
Studie in der SZ mit der schönen
Überschrift warten ohne Ablenkung ist
besser als gedacht
also an ein Mann von der
Uni Tübingen hat ein Experiment gemacht
mit 260 Leuten ungefähr und die die
Probanden sollten vor einer Wartezeit
von 20 Minuten einschätzen wie sich das
Allein sein anfühlen würde ja das heißt
Smartphones nämlich eine Smartphones
kein lesen kein herumlaufen nichts und
das interessante Ergebnis ist die Leute
fanden es angenehmer Zeit einfach nur
mit ihren Gedanken zu verbringen als sie
vorher gedacht hatten und dann kann
gehandelt haben die diesen Zustand
vorher in ihrem Leben nicht kann weil
das hätte ich auch vorher gesagt also 20
Minuten warten wenn ich jetzt nicht in
Isis Kälte ist oder so oder in
unsicherer Umgebung ja finde ich jetzt
du würdest sagen also was bei den 20
Minuten war war im Grunde dann der
gesamte Kindheit ich würde sagen ja bei
uns war das ja so wir mussten uns ich
meine der Reichtum an innerer Welt ja
entsteht häufig dadurch dass gerade in
der äußeren Welt nichts los ist
ja wirklich so ja klar ja also du baust
umso mehr Reichtum an innerer Welt auf
je mehr du gezwungen bist ich mit deinen
eigenen Gedanken zu amüsieren du
brauchst natürlich diese außen Anreize
das ist schon klar aber wenn du dauernd
aus und Anreize hast entsteht kein
Reichtum mein innerer Welt das hier
nicht nötig der muss ja nicht aufbauen
und das der größte Schatz den man durch
sein Leben tragen kann der Reichtum an
innere Welt ist ja brauche ich Dir nicht
zu erzählen weil die Ablenkung hast du
in deinen langen polarn Nächten ja auch
nicht ja da bist du ja auch komplett auf
dich selbst angeglichen total also die
die die die Fähigkeit sozusagen von
Menschen in ihr eigenes Denken
einzutauchen und sich darin quasi
aufzulösen die ist glaube ich viel
größer als gedacht und und eigentlich
das ist eigentlich irre dass wir
heutzutage Studien darüber machen müssen
weil uns offenbar die Tatsache dass es
so ist die die haben wir gar nicht mal
so auf dem Schirm das ist uns gar nicht
mehr so klar weil die Ablenkung
mittlerweile vollkommen ist ja so ist
das
und die Frage ist natürlich immer was
was macht das mit uns ne also triggert
ja was wenn wenn sozusagen die die die
die die die Idee ist das ist immer von
morgens bis abends irgendwie spektakulär
sein muss also dieser der alltägliche
Bedarf an außer alltäglich ja ist
ungefähr das Hundertfache von dem was es
vor 100 Jahren war das meine ich und und
ich sag mal die moderne
Unterhaltungsindustrie und in dem Fall
ist es ja eigentlich wenn du es mal
genau nimmst ist es im Speziellen das
mobile Endgerät ja alles Menschen dann
in der Hand halten
das gaukelt dir das ja vor das
Entertainment ist vollkommen absolut
so ist das vielfach beschrieben vielfach
erklärt und die Frage die Du gerade
gestellt hast immer noch unbeantwortet
was macht das mit uns das ist ganz ganz
schwer zu sagen ich glaube das kann man
auch nicht in einem Satz zusammenfassen
man könnte ja zu kulturpessimistisch
sagen ja die Leute bauen keinen Reichtum
an innerer Welt mehr auf und ähm ohne
Ablenkung werden die wahnsinnig und so
weiter aber diese Studie hat ja gezeigt
ja dass das vielleicht auch sogar mal
als erfrischend wahrgenommen wird und
vielleicht
lege der positive Schluss darin dass man
vielleicht auch erstmal lernen muss mit
diesen 100 Millionen außen reizen
umzugehen und dann wieder die Fähigkeit
zu entwickeln sich vor Aufmerksamkeit
Raub zu schützen also sein Gehirn in
Sicherheit zu bringen weil sie sich so
sein und so weiter dass das ja auch
etwas ist was man trainieren kann oder
trainieren muss wenn man das selber in
Griff hat ja ob man den den außen reizen
folgt oder ob man sich in sich selbst
versenkt wenn man das selbst im Griff
hat dann wäre die große Zahl der
Außenreize eigentlich kein Problem mehr
ist richtig ja und deswegen bin ich seit
jeher der Überzeugung dass das in der
Schule gelernt werden müsste und das
Meditation Meditation Kontemplation und
Konzentration in die Schule gehört und
zwar nicht als Fach indem man Klausuren
schreibt sondern als praktische Übung
indem man es einfach tut
angeleitet wird das zu tun ja weil das
ist glaube ich schon so also was ich
feststelle weil du gerade über Kinder
sprichst das macht definitiv Kinder
hibbelig und nervös es senkt auch so die
die Frustrationstoleranz habe ich immer
das Gefühl also wenn wenn wenn nicht
sofort irgendwie der der nächste Spaß um
die Ecke kommt dann ist dann dann wird
man unruhig und irgendwann dann auch
aggressiv also das muss dann schon sein
und deswegen habe ich das Gefühl dass
der der also das ist eigentlich eine
Form von Abhängigkeit ist da gibt klar
dagegen anzuarbeiten glaube ich das wäre
auch ein Vorsatz für 2023 für Eltern und
ja und auch für Kinder ja dann Richard
eine Sache Sache die mir persönlich
wichtig und eigentlich auch fast
untergegangen weil dieses Jahr so voll
war an ja ein schlimme Nachrichten die
alles überlagert haben im speziell
natürlich hier mit der Krieg in der
Ukraine aber um 23 10 meldet die
Tagesschau das sei man ruhig die nach
einem Angriff im August auf einem Auge
blind ist
das hat mich damals aus den Latschen
gehauen weil ich Salman rutscht die
mehrfach begegnet bin weil ich den auch
wirklich persönlich sehr sehr mag weil
mich diese Lebensgeschichte immer
berührt hat und weil wir sogar
gelegentlich mal werden so eine ganz
ganz oberflächliche aber dennoch
Bekanntschaften wir am ab und zu mal
telefoniert und uns geschrieben und als
dann dieses Attentat passiert ist habe
ich ihm natürlich auch geschrieben und
hat dann aber nie mehr eine Antwort
bekommen und ich weiß jetzt nicht wie es
ihm wirklich geht also ich lese dann
eben nur das auf einem Auge blind ist
das eine Hand nicht mehr bewegen kann
und das an einem geheimen Ort
mittlerweile untergebracht ist das heißt
und ich glaube das ist der schlimmste
Teil für ihn weil der der Alptraum den
er so viele Jahre hatte nachdem dieser
fatwanger dieses Todesurteil über ihn
aus gesprochen worden war vom iranischen
Regime hat ja dazu geführt dass dieser
Mensch ein Leben gelebt hat über viele
Jahre hinweg das kann man sich nicht
vorstellen der der hat das mal berichtet
bei uns in der Sendung sagt er weiß das
war so wenn wenn der Postbote geklingelt
hat dann habe ich mich prinzipiell
erstmal unterm Küchentisch versteckt bei
mir zu Hause weil ich nie wusste ist das
ein echter Postbote oder ist das
irgendein Killer den wir dass das Regime
aus dir angeschickt hat ja so war sein
Leben Jahre und Jahrzehnte lang und war
denn das wenn jetzt so euch in die
Sendung gekommen ist mit mit wie viel
Personenschützern wäre gar nicht gar
nicht
den Albtraum eigentlich gefühlt schon
los gewesen genau er hat irgendwann
beschlossen ich
macht das nicht mehr er wusste dass er
weiterhin gefährdet war das wusste er
hat dann auch irgendwann ein ein Buch
darüber geschrieben in dem man das alles
noch mal aufgearbeitet hat und so weiter
aber er wollte das loswerden und er hat
es damals auch erzählt und sagte weißt
du ich war bis 1989 war ich ein sehr
erfolgreicher Schriftsteller ja und am
14 Februar 89 Valentinstag begann
sozusagen sein Leben danach dieses
zweite Leben da kriegt er nämlich das
war total irre den Anruf einer BBC
Reporterin dem folgende Frage stellt wie
fühlt man sich wenn man weiß dass man
gerade von einer toller comeni zum Tode
verurteilt worden ist
die ruft ihn an und sagt ihm was man auf
folgendes ist gerade Sache das heißt der
Lift also jetzt seit 33 Jahren ja damit
und irgendwann war das kein großes Thema
mehr sein Leben hat sich weitgehend
normalisiert genau dachte er dachte er
dachte
er und beginnt dieser Albtraum abgesehen
davon was den körperlich passiert ist
wieder von neu dass der Punkt und es
geht es geht immer sozusagen um diese
dieses große Lebensthema es geht immer
um die Frage Religion was macht
eigentlich Religion wenn sie dann
irgendwann fanatisch wird wenn sie
extremistisch wird was macht die mit mit
Menschen und er hat dem immer so sein
Humor entgegengesetzt sei man ruhig die
hat einen ganz großartigen feinen Humor
ich weiß auch der hat ich bin immer mal
gefragt wie das eigentlich ist in
Amerika jetzt und was eigentlich
wirklich der Plan von von Donald Trump
ist dann sagt er da musste er gut also
es geht in Wahrheit nicht darum make
America great again sondern es geht um
America white again ja also lasst uns
Amerika wieder weiß machen das war so
sein feiner subtiler Humor der hat das
aufgespießt wie wie kann man anderer und
er sagt auch immer Humor ist die Waffe
wenn sonst nichts mehr geht und hat sich
dann eben gesagt zehn Jahre und dann
Küchentisch versteckt in der Postbote
klingelt hat sich auf dem Klo versteckt
wenn die Putzfrau kam ja und
hat dann irgendwann beschlossen ich will
dieses Leben nicht mehr und jetzt bei
einer Lesung im August irgendwo in einer
Ostküste in der Nähe von New York hat
sie erwischt ist ein 24-jähriger
libanesischer Herkunft auf ihn los und
hat dutzende mal auf ihn eingestochen
und hat ihn dann offenbar so schwer
verletzt dass er jetzt auf einem Auge
dauerhaft blind ist und er hat nicht
mehr bewegen kann ich dachte einer der
der sich so der so mutig war und der
sich der sich so gegen diesen religiösen
Fundament Tourismus und diesen Wahnsinn
gestellt hat der darf nicht am Ende
verlieren weißt du dass das geht so
nicht der der allein weißt du du gehst
auf die Straße
wann traust du dich sozusagen über die
Straße zu laufen ohne die jemals
umzudrehen klar ja klar wann traust du
dich wieder deinen Namen an der Klinge
leben wir zu schreiben
er hat das so beschrieben er sagte mein
Leben war ein Leben durch Hintertüren
ich kalte kannte alle Hintertüren dieser
Welt alle alle bin immer nur die
Hintertür rein und raus Wahnsinn ja und
das wollte er nicht na ja und es ist ihm
dann zum Feiern traurig
ja hast du immer erlebt also habe ich
Wahnsinn ja ich denke auch immer das ist
natürlich jetzt ein ganz spezielle
Geschichte aber der Fluch der
monotheistischen Religionen
der besteht ja immer darin dass es nur
einen geben kann und monotheistische
Religion haben es dann häufig an sich
wie das Christentum oder wie der Islam
die missionieren richtig ja die wollen
das die anderen werden wie sie genau das
war der Vorteil der politikistischen
Religion die viele Götter haben das
haben die nie gemacht die Griechen und
die Römer haben nie versucht anderen
Völkern ihre Götter aufzuzwingen oder
die alten Ägypter haben das nicht
gemacht ich glaube die News machen das
auch nicht weil das ist ja wenn du
sowieso einen ganzen Kosmos voller
Götter hast ja ob das da ein mehr oder
weniger gibt ist er nicht die
entscheidende Frage sondern es ist ja
diese
einzigartigkeitsanspruch der
monotheistischen religionismus vorführt
genau ja und da haben ja beide Religion
ich meine das Christentum hat eine Mods
blutige Geschichte und der Islam eben
auch und es ist zu gruselig dass ein
solches Relikt wo man auch das Gefühl
hat dass er doch in diesem Jahrhundert
nichts mehr verloren dass das immer noch
völlig alle gegenwärtig ja aber es kommt
zurück ne ich weiß er hatte damals auch
in diesem Buch
Joseph Anton hieß das also das war
sozusagen eher eine
andere Name den er sich da gegeben hat
das war seine Geschichte da das schreibt
er das Todesurteil gegen mich war der
Beginn von etwas wir leben in einer
Gesellschaft deren Plage die Rückkehr
der Religionen ist und zwar nicht nur
des Islams in Amerika sehen Sie die
Erstarkung der christlichen Rechten in
Indien eine Erhebung des rechten
Hinduismus und Pakistan ist heute ein
dunkler Ort
und was was ich auch so toll an dem man
fand
ist das er sehr in der Lage war zu
differenzieren ich meine sei man ruhig
die hätte allen Grund gehabt sondern den
Islam an sich
gemacht
das war nie sozusagen die Rede gegen den
Islam der hat auch nie Muslime äh in
Sippenhaft genommen für das was dort mit
ihm gemacht wurde hat immer gesagt der
der real existieren Islam ist heute zu
seinem eigenen Gift geworden an dem vor
allen Dingen Muslime sterben das hat er
immer alles klar stimmt das ist übrigens
auch richtig auch die terroristischen
Anschläge ja finden viel mehr in der
muslimischen sich selber statt als in
christlichen Kindern genau und das heißt
die die die Leute die einfach ganz
normale Muslime sind die leiden am
meisten das ist das Bittere daran unter
diesen diesen fanatischen Typ aber ich
wie wir dieses Jahr äußerst Leid Feuer
im Iran wieder erlebt haben zum Beispiel
zum Beispiel und am Ende geht es
also die die Moral wird immer
vorgeschoben die Ideologie wird
vorgeschoben überhaupt geht es einfach
Kohle es geht um macht es geht um
Einfluss ja es geht eben nichts anderes
wie immer aber mich hat das hat das
wirklich
berührt weil ich so dachte dass das kann
doch nicht sein das kann doch wirklich
nicht sein
ja und dann auch so ein Thema von dem
ich weiß dass es dir am Herzen liegt
alternativer Nobelpreis ja Uganda geht
um Uganda eine riesige Pipeline die
gebaut werden soll die längste
Ölpipeline der Welt ja in Uganda es geht
um Abholzung von Regenwäldern wie immer
es geht um Vertreibung es geht um
Enteignung das soll ein
ein Ölfeld ausgebeutet werden in ugand
an dem Uganda natürlich dann auch mit
verdienen sollst
große ölmutig sind schon am Start total
aus Frankreich ein großer Öl Multi aus
China und so weiter die Regierungen
die Engländer Konzessionen gekauft im
Kongo so ebenfalls Regenwald übrigens
auch Gorilla Gebiet ist ja und da steht
ja absolut eben in der in der Home Range
der Berg gorillas sind ölrechte verkauft
ein englischen Ölkonzern da stellt man
sich doch mal folgende Frage ich meine
die ganze Welt ja oder oder jedenfalls
Menschen bei uns alle lieben Gorillas ja
und alle wissen wie wichtig der
Regenwald ist und und wie wenig noch
übrig ist und so weiter wie ist es dann
überhaupt möglich das westliche
Mineralölkonzerne ohne in die komplette
Ächtung zu geben total ja immer noch den
alten Stiefel fahren und gucken wo kann
man Öl kriegen und dann auf Teufel komm
raus und das im wahrsten Sinne das Zeug
zu fördern das kann doch gar nicht mehr
sein und was sind das für Regierungen in
diesen Ländern ist das Frankreich oder
England oder wer auch immer dahinter ist
die damit kein Problem haben wieso ist
das nicht verboten es stimmt ja also du
könntest in Frankreich ja kein Öl in
einem Naturschutzgebiet fördern ja aber
du kannst als französischer
Mineralölkonzern kannst du Öl in einem
Naturschutzgebiete in einem Nationalpark
ja
fördern und und in lauter Regionen die
aus guten Gründen geschützt sind und so
weiter
wieso passiert da nichts wieso gibt es
da kein internationales Naturschutzrecht
das grundsätzlich sagt ja in den und den
und den Regionen der Welt und das
müssten ziemlich viele sein ja ist
Schluss damit ja aber soll ich dir mal
was sagen weißt du was die simple
Antwort ist und die geht dann jetzt
ehrlich gesagt auch wirklich in unsere
Richtung die Wahrheit ist weil wir wir
Medien auch unseren Job nicht machen ich
meine von vom vom African Institut für
ENERGY und Governance ja das sind die
diese kleine Umweltorganisation die
jetzt diesen alternativen Nobelpreis
gekriegt hat weil sie gegen diese
Pipeline kämpfen dort ja gegen diese
politische Willkür ganz ehrlich ich habe
in der Beschäftigung jetzt für den
Podcast habe ich glaube das zweite mal
davon gelesen aber wirklich ernsthaft
auseinander sein
und wir haben uns alle nicht
aufgegriffen und ich muss dann immer an
John Stewart denken der der über Medien
mal gesagt hat die sind ja nicht böse
sie sind einfach nur sensationsgeil und
faul
und das das denke ich mal okay es ist
böse zugespitzt aber irgendwie machen
wir an manchen Stellen wirklich unseren
Job nicht kümmern stürzen uns auf
nebensächlich sehr großer Teil Johnny
Depp und business
as usual das was die großen
Nachrichtenagenturen eben groß bringen
das bringt man dann selber groß sondern
richtig noch größer und dann fällt ganz
viel Licht da fuls Mist und viel viel zu
wenig ja und viel viel zu wenig Licht
fällt auf den Regenwald und auf die
Pipeline und so das ist in der Tat so
ich meine es gibt eine Initiative die
sagt man müsste Stadt Börse vor acht
Umwelt vor acht machen ja oder Klima vor
acht ja dass man einfach so fünf Minuten
genau das waren dann jemand ist so wie
jetzt die netten Damen die und Herren
die da von der Börse berichten und das
auch ganz toll machen ja aber genauso
müsste sozusagen die wichtigsten Dinge
zusammengefasst werden wie es um diese
Dinge steht was ist da neues gibt
ja und da müsste man jeden Tag sozusagen
den Brief werden und ich meine wir haben
doch geredet ne von von einer
moralkultur die die den Gürtel immer
enger zieht aber nicht in diesen Fragen
nicht in diesen existenziellen Fragen
dass wir sagen Mineralölkonzerne die
solche Pipelines bauen werden echt
ja oder Wirtschaftssanktionen gegen
Länder das würde Uganda sehr weh tun ja
die solche Konzessionen vergeben
ja unter dem Gesichtspunkt weltnatur
Erbe ja Gorillas Regenwald
als Lunge ja alles das gehört der
Menschheit die Menschheit braucht keine
Gorillas aber sie braucht den Regenwald
als Lunge genau
anderes Thema Richard anderes Thema zum
Schluss
Michael Jackson Thriller wird 40 und
alle schwarzer wird 80
ich würde sagen zu beiden fällt mir nur
begrenzt was ein also Michael Jackson
hat auf meine musikalische Biografie ein
Einfluss von 0 gehabt
nie und zu keinem Zeitpunkt Michael
Jackson Fan ich habe hier noch nie
besonders bewundert weil er ja
eigentlich doch eher nur ein Performer
war hätte seine Musik nicht selber
gemacht also wenn man mal guckt was
fällt ein Hype um Michael Jackson
gemacht wurde in Relation zu Prince was
für ein musikalisches Genie Prinzessin
gewesen ist und was für ein
eingeschränktes musikalisches Chemie
Michael Jackson also da liegen ja Welten
zwischen naja auf jeden Fall ist das für
mich irgendwie nicht das große Thema
Alice Schwarzer ist natürlich jemand den
ich aus meiner Kindheit kenne nicht
persönlich aber im Fernsehen gesehen ich
habe eine Fernsehsendung gesehen ich
schätze mal ich war um die zehn
wo esta Villa und alles schwarzer
miteinander geredet haben und was mir
vor allen Dingen in Erinnerung blieb war
diese unglaubliche Zigarettenrauch in
der Luft
und es ging aber die Frage ob die Männer
die Frauen unterdrücken oder nicht und
Esser wie laber der Überzeugung
eigentlich sind die Männer die anderen
Schweine in der Gesellschaft ja die
schwarzer sein das natürlich ganz ganz
anders und meine Mutter war natürlich
100% auf Seiten von Aldi schwarze und
meine Mutter gehörte dann auch zu den
frühen berufenden der Frauenbewegung und
wenn die frauenbewegungsfrauen sich
trafen dieser Kreis ja dann war das da
in dieser Höhle in der die sich trafen
mindestens so vor raucht wie in diesem
Fernsehstudio also für mich ist
Feminismus und exzessiver Nikotin Genuss
untrennbar in meinem Gehirn geschweigert
und ich würde mal über alles schwarzer
sagen dass sie zu dieser Zeit eine enorm
wichtige Rolle in der Gesellschaft
gespielt hat und ich glaube das
bezweifelt auch niemand und man muss
sich auch überlegen welchen
unglaublichen Anfeindungen man damals
mit feministischen Positionen noch
ausgesetzt war also man hat ja auch die
größtenteil der Frauen damals gegen sich
also ich anständigen Frauen die also mit
dem manzen und sowas nichts zu tun haben
also hat man sich immer vorgestellt die
sind irgendwie hässlich und lesbisch und
was weiß ich was unser sagen sie übelste
Behandlung des Themas und durch dieses
steige Wetter ist hier also viele
Jahrzehnte hindurch
und ich denke das ist eine historische
Leistung die wird ja keiner nehmen und
die wird Ihnen heute wird ihr das jeder
als Leistung zugestehen was damals hoch
umstritten wie man heute war sagt und
ich denke das ist gut dass alles
schwarzer diese Rolle gespielt hat
total ich ganz persönlich ich habe sie
mehrfach getroffen und wir hatten einmal
richtig intensives Gespräch und da kamen
sie dann hinterher zu mir und sagte mein
lieber das war nicht in Ordnung was sie
da heute mit mir gemacht haben ich habe
sie nach ihren steuergeschichten
und ich muss aber sagen auf der
persönlichen Ebene ist da nie was übrig
geblieben und wenn man so so dann so
direkt angegangen wird dann kriegt man
so eine Idee davon was alles schwarzer
ist und was eigentlich schwarzer
ausmacht und ich habe die immer
wahnsinnig gemocht genau deswegen weil
sie völlig ohne Scheu einfach total auf
dich losgeht und ich fand und finde das
auch in Sendungen immer unglaublich
belebend wenn sich jemand das traut fand
interessant was sie dann in der späteren
Phase ihres Lebens jetzt gemacht hat sie
ist ja nicht mehr uneingeschränkt die
Ionen nee
von von Frauen und und
wer kann denn ein deutungsanspruch über
ein Geschlecht haben also das ist eine
Frage die man sich nicht in der Frage
sozusagen des revolutionären Kampfes
stellt wie in den 70ern aber jetzt ist
ja die Frage kann Alice Schwarzer für
die Frauen sprechen sie hat ja keinen
Mandat von denen Frauen ja und ganz
viele Frauen sehen die Welt anders als
alles schwarz auch wenn sie ihr viel
verdanken genau und das macht die Sache
heute natürlich wahnsinnig schwierig
weil es gibt sozusagen diese diese Kaste
was Frauen ja früher gewesen sind ja mit
angegeben diese Kasten insofern als dass
sie ohne ohne Unterschrift ihres Garten
kein Mietvertrag unterzeichnen konnten
oder kein Konto eröffnen ja also
wirklich eine gewisse allgemeine
Rechtlosigkeit in entscheidenden Fragen
haben die ist ja heute nicht mehr da und
damit ist natürlich der Individualismus
bei den Frauen auch sehr viel größer als
früher war das heißt also jede Frau hat
eine andere sich der Welt und dann ist
es wahnsinnig schwierig für die Frauen
noch zu sprechen und das ein bisschen
Ihre Frage ja weil sie das natürlich
nach wie vor ja und weil sie das auch
sozusagen ihre Verdienst der auf diesem
Weg hat aber hier ist sozusagen die
Klientel für die sie spricht die ist ja
schon sehr weitgehend glaube ich
verloren gegangen was das persönliche
anbelangt ich war ja auch mal mit ihr
zusammen mit einer Sendung sogar in
einer Sendung bei dir und da muss man
sagen wir haben uns herzlich nicht
gemocht
wirklich ja ja
nach der Kölner Silvesternacht okay ja
und ich weiß dass sie gesagt hat diese
Übergriffe die damals passiert sind und
diese an grabschereien und sowas wären
einen Angriff auf den deutschen
Feminismus gewesen
und das habe ich ein bisschen anders
gesehen nämlich naja ich glaube die
Leute die das da gemacht haben ja also
dieses jüngeren Leute von den fast alle
aus dem Magret starten kam die wissen
gar nicht was der deutsche Feminismus
ist das richtig ja die haben das nicht
als politische Tat im Fuß was sie da
gemacht haben ja der ganze Scheiß und
der ganze Mist hatte verdient überhaupt
nichts mit Politik zu tun
ich würde gerne Schluss machen Richard
mit mit einem noch mal ein großartiger
Gedanke von Salman ruschi der irgendwo
mal geschrieben hat wir sollten uns
darüber im Klaren sein dass die Welt in
der wir leben wollen auch die Welt ist
in der wir leben und diese Welt sollten
mir nicht faulen Kompromissen Opfern
denn wenn Sie versuchen einen Schläger
zu besänftigen damit er sie nicht
weniger sondern viel härter verprügeln
und deswegen ist die einzige wirksame
Methode konfrontiere ihn das ist eine
Ansage und ich glaube aber bestimmten
Punkten ist genau das dass meins dass
man braucht ja ich glaube wir müssen wir
brauchen mehr Konfrontationen in den
wichtigen Dingen in moralischer Hinsicht
und weniger Konfrontation in den
unwichtigen Dinge so
womit wir wieder bei Will Smith werden
und ich glaube die Kunst die wichtigen
von den unwichtigen Dingen zu
unterscheiden darüber können wir uns
auch mal unterhalten genau also Richard
ich danke sehr das war ja auch mal das
ganze Jahr erfinde ich auch es hat mir
wirklich ein Quell unerschöpflicher
Freude mich mit dir zu unterhalten
wirklich
den heiligen aber ich würde auch sagen
das ist immer eine spezielle Stunde in
der Woche ja ist so was in diesem Sinne
wir sehen uns und hören uns im neuen
Jahr machen wir bis dann danke dir
tschüss alles tschüss
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]